turning now to the presidential race the
trump campaign wants an
extra debate with presumptive democratic
nominee joe biden about a month from now
before early voting begins in some
states
three debates are scheduled right now
september 29th
october 15th and october 22nd ed o'keefe
is covering campaign
2020 all right ed so what else could
change between now and november
everything vlad first as the debate over
debates continues both parties are now
completely scrapping plans to hold
anything resembling normal
political conventions the biden campaign
announced that neither he
his running mate nor any party leader
will speak for milwaukee at the
democratic national convention
as originally planned democrats now say
the city of milwaukee will serve as a
control room of sorts for a completely
virtual convention
that will include joe biden accepting
the nomination from his home state of
delaware
republicans already scrapped plans for
their convention in jacksonville florida
and charlotte north carolina and
president trump is now considering
accepting his party's nomination
from the white house i think it would be
a very convenient idea
something that we threw out it would be
very cost conscious by comparison to any
other location
but some including members of the
president's own party
questioned whether that would violate
the hatch act of federal law prohibiting
government officials from participating
in politics
and the use of government property for
campaign activity
republican senator john thune said i
think anything you do on federal
property
would seem to be problematic the
president brushed off legal concerns
noting
he's exempt from the act well it is
legal
there is no hatch act because it doesn't
pertain to the president
house speaker nancy pelosi said it would
not happen and called it a distraction
and he is diverting attention from the
fact
that people are dying in our country as
the president and biden continue
campaigning virtually
the former vice president took questions
at a conference of black and latino
journalists
and was asked what he would do about
border security
trump campaigned on build that wall are
you willing to tear that wall down
there will not be another foot of wall
constructed
in my administration biden also said
that if he's president border protection
would be based on high technology
as for his running mate we're still
standing by for that announcement but
the former vice president tweeted last
night quote
i'll let you know soon vlad
and we will be waiting and okay for us
thank you ed as always we appreciate it